the greatest challenge was having to
overcome working with Chris and his
terrible choices she made
don't do that I am Kaylee Cuoco and I'm
Christmasy and the cast and I are
sharing some of our favorite moments
from peacock's new original series based
on a true story we need to talk I
literally can't with that and what you
just showed me that makes me sick
it's me kissing Christmas Cena
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
when I first read this script it was
like nothing else I'd ever read before
um it was so out of the box the tone
will at least for me is the tone that I
thrive in basically chaotic kind of
don't know what it is it's funny it's
sad it's scary all the things which I
love playing they were so great on this
show all of the creatives Let Us
improvise play with the script play with
the story Craig our show runner he was
so open to us me and Chris and Kaylee
just adding things in taking them away
really taking ownership of of the
characters and the story we just kept
making stuff up you were here you were
hysterical too
now he's here so I [__] Ripper as he
didn't find me attractive enough to kill
but whatever oh really really I'm just
saying we had so much fun shooting that
scene which is the one where you and I
realized that Matt is the killer oh yeah
girl
my toilet guy
hey
a showerful secret I mean can you even
if they knew he was like hey guys
hey hey hi hi we did a lot of this
we got told to take it down yeah a lot
and got told to stop ad living yeah go
back please calm down and we gotta get
to lunch yep um but that was one of my
favorites favorite too yeah
my favorite scene to film was a scene
very early on when I'm in a diner with
Chris Messina I got you a chocolate
croissant from the counter I'm not here
for croissants oh you sure
man they're so good
oh
and I loved it just because it was such
a playful scene we got to just sit down
in this Diner and just go at each other
and there are so many mind games going
on you took a while to call me back
maybe you weren't really committed your
proposal both of our characters were
almost at their Pinnacle of where we'd
seen them at that point
um and just been able to start with
Chris all day was so fun I'm fully in
no matter what
are you in or out however one of the
really difficult things about it was I
did have to eat two croissants in each
take towards the end of the day I was
kind of going a bit green
um and I remember Chris leaning in going
okay man and I remember thinking I'm
just gonna throw up in your lap man no
one should eat 32 croissant
I think it's totally [__] disgusting
it was like a week-long shoot for the
dinner table scene in episode six yes so
are you part of the crew now it was nice
because the whole cast was together and
we all have a really good Dynamic yes
the West Side Ripper has some kind of
brain defect but these parasites are
making money off of him they should go
to prison longer than he does that's a
very good point the dog was amazing one
of the best actors I've worked with
no he's right up there you know it's sad
he stole a lot of your like he stole a
lot of the I don't think he was the best
he was very he was great and he was
great I hope that you learned something
I did learn a lot with him he kept quiet
not the nicest guy
come to me
that was pretty crazy that was wild we
knew it was gonna happen obviously but
I've never seen a person no on fire so
that was just insane
the greatest challenge was working with
her yeah it was really really hard
exhausting and
um not having enough scenes with
Christmas
laughs
[Music]